right so hello everyone so it asked me
to give maybe a gentle introduction or
as I hope to the sort of viewpoint on
expansion on higher dimensional
expansion in particular that sort of in
a sense historically at least preceded
maybe the spectral one at least much of
it and that that is more sort of
motivated by geometry and topology and
indeed my background is in computational
topology and applications of topological
methods so anyway my understanding is
that many of you may not be working with
cohomology on a daily basis so I thought
I start with a basic introduction so let
X be finance and peripheral complex so
just a finite set system closed
undertaking subsets in many of the
previous lectures that just means that
we can kind of decompose X in two layers
where this is just the empty set x0 r is
the set of vertices X 1 is the set of
edges or pair which is a certain set of
pairs of vertices
x2 is a subset of triples and so forth
and we have certain incidences between
these just given by the by the
containment structure now in ecology you
essentially look at an algebraic version
of this and the simplest one that I want
to focus on is you look at vector spaces
over the field with two elements and
then topologists call these Co chains or
something strange but I will call them
Co chains so let me introduce this
notation see K of X is really the same
as see K of X with Z two coefficients is
just what I just wrote there see two
so these are just functions from the K
simply sees okay now we have incidence
relations which we can think of as
bipartite graphs between adjacent layers
and these naturally give rise to linear
maps between these vector spaces or
functions so I should say these are
called and these linear maps are called
Co boundary operators maybe I should use
a different color because it's
um so this thing is called a mongrel
right
- fancy word and it's just given by the
incidence relation but let's spell it
out so if we have a function in let's
say a - one coach a function from a came
from K minus one simply cease to the two
then what is it Co boundary it's a
function that eats K simply sees of K
plus 1 vertices which I will label V 0 V
1 V K and so what does it mean that it's
the linear map that's given by the
incidence relation so by the by by the
matrix that encodes the bipartite
incidence graph well it just means that
if I have this K simplex I look at all
the K minus 1 simply sees that that are
contained in it and I sum up the values
of my function on these
throw one out
so the apologist would put ahead here
I'll just cross it off okay so that's
the definition of a compounder operator
so far so good
let's look at a few examples so for
instance if well it would be the up
operator with the difference that you
kind of saw okay so here I haven't yet
thought this one doesn't depend on any
probability distribution which is one
but morally speaking it's it's
essentially that's the other main
difference yes but I will but I will
come to this everything I am sorry so
this is really as a function were -
thank you very much focus yes okay so
let's see if F is in here then it's just
a function that assigns 0 or 1 to the
empty set so it's just a constant
and then Delta of F it's a single vertex
and it's the same constant on every
vertex
if we have zero-dimensional coaching so
that's just the zero one valued function
on the vertices or in other words a
subset of vertices then Delta F of let's
say an edge UV is just the sum of over
the endpoints again mod two
so this is zero if the two values are
the same and one otherwise so in other
words it's if I think of this is maybe
my this is f equal to 1 and this is f
equal to zero then this is Delta F it's
just a cut defined by this function
that's maybe do one more so if F is in
c1 of X so that just means it's a subset
of edges and then Delta F of a triangle
as a you W is just I take my function on
the edges and I sum it up mod 2 over the
three edges
that's uh no forget writing
so now it's an easy exercise that if I
take the co bond rate in some of some
dimension I should really use indices
but they get cumbersome so I start in
some dimension I don't know I I go up
one dimension to I plus one and then I
do this again so I go up to dimension I
plus two this is you the reason is
following so what I really do is I have
some I end up in subsets of size let's
say I plus two so I have some I will
have some set s Union two particular
vertices and then I will do this twice
so in the first operation I would go
over all subsets that have one element
less and then I would sum again over all
subsets that have one element less than
that so in the end I will sum up over
all repeatedly in a certain sense over
subsets that have two elements less and
for each subset that has two elements
less I have two ways of going down I can
either first remove a and then B or the
other way around
because I distinguish these two ways in
the way I'm summing up I get zero what
you look to so this means that the
kernel the image of okay the image of
Delta let's say from CK minus 1 of X CK
of X
it's contained in the kernel of the
following Banco boundary operator
these images these are called code
boundaries k-dimensional Coburn Ruiz
and the elements in the kernel are
called Co cycles
and because I have so this is a linear
subspace this is a linear subspace that
this containment so I can form the
quotient
one little example let's look at this
inclusion complex six vertices despite
of what you might think you see so this
just means that the things on the
boundary are identified so this is the
same vertex as this this is just an
easier way of drawing with simplicial
complex what's going on so this means
that I have six vertices I have actually
uh
if you can you can easily see that I
have all the six choose two edges and I
have one two three four five six ten
triangles so let's look for instance at
this one-dimensional cocaine so remember
one dimensional coaching is the zero one
valued function on the edges or a subset
of edges
what is it go boundary
every triangle is incident to an even
number of edges right exactly these
triangles don't see any red edges and
the ones in the middle see - so that's
it so this is actually a one dimensional
call cycle on the other end
I can ask look at this definition of
comala G so here I would look at the
call cycle so this is definitely a KO
cycle
what do you know the core boundaries so
if I look at this thing as defining an
element in chrome ology I can ask myself
is it trivial that would mean so it's
definitely a call cycle but is it a KO
boundary
well this in this case we can easily
check let's suppose it is a call
boundary this means it would be the core
boundary of some set of vertices well
let's look at this vertex I mean
definitely some of the endpoints have to
be well they all have to be assigned
values the call boundary the cut across
the number the edges across the cut of
vertices doesn't change if I flip the
sides so I can assume that this side
gets one it gets zero then clearly this
vertex needs to get one then this one
also needs to get one this one needs to
get zero this one needs to get value one
and this is turning black
and this one needs to get zero but this
is already a contradiction
so this means that this particular
one-dimensional coal cycle witnesses the
fact that my complex is non-trivial
first ecology many of you a bit of
simplistic analogy will know that this
is the protective plane or a
triangulation of the protective plane so
this actually this space actually has
first column ology exactly it will to
set to so there's a single generator
okay so that's that's all good and well
of course you can ask why would one care
well okay one answer is that ecology is
the fundamental notion in topology and
mathematics in general let me maybe give
you a slightly more concrete motivation
so as I mentioned I work in all sorts of
questions related to the intersection
between community taric's and topology
or community oryx and geometry and one
basic question that one basic type of
problem that often occurs is that you
have some simplicial complex that semi
encodes your combinatorial problem and
you look at maps from this simplicial
complex to some Euclidean space so I
mean a very basic version of this that
you can think of is you have a graph and
you might want to draw it in the plane
with may be as few crossings as possible
but so let me just consider and for
simplicity let me assume that the map is
linear
some Euclidean space
so by this adjust by a linear map I just
mean I map the vertices somewhere
wherever I want and then I interpolate
the rest linearly so an edge would be
mapped to the segment joining the two
end points a triangle would be mapped to
the convex hull of the three end points
and so forth but everything I'll say
will will work more generally but just
for simplicity let me focus on this
for instance if since this was so
popular let's look at the fish complex
so this could be X and then my map well
I don't really know many things that I
could do so in particular I mean I just
want to illustrate that I in no way want
to assume that I have an embedding so
maybe I map these vertices like this and
then maybe I fold
this will be math okay why not
so the reason I mention is because I
want to give a bit more geometric
meaning to the notion of Co chains and
co boundaries and Co cycles so let's
consider a point
that is in some sense generic or in
general position so in the plane for
instance a generic point wouldn't end up
lying on the image of a vertex or on an
edge because if I wiggle that goes away
but it could very well end up in the
interior of a triangle maybe here I
don't let's say this is P so P
all right and now what I want to look at
are all the simplices let's say the D
simply sees whose image contains P and I
will denote this by f-sharp of P you can
imagine that this sharp is a weird way
of writing minus 1 so this is like the
inverse image but for various reasons I
don't want to write f inverse so this is
just the set of these simply C's so this
is I have to find it here as a set but
of course this is the same as a cocaine
with c2 collisions assign one to the T
simply sees that contain despondency rod
was so note that's kind of the main
point of this remark
f sharp of P is actually a co boundary
why this is the reason is the following
so you take your point and you pick your
favorite ray that emanates from this
point to infinity
I keep
and suppose again that is raised kind of
generic meaning in the plane I don't
want it to pass through any point in
general row should not pass
simplices of donation t - - well then I
claim that P is the co boundary of F
sharp of Rho which is the set of all D
minus one simply sees intersecting row
right because if my point lies in the
interior of a triangle and I go to
infinity I have to cross the boundary
once if it doesn't lie in the interior
of my triangle then either row will miss
it entirely so for instance row misses
this triangle entirely or it might
encounter the triangle but then it has
to go in and out again because I wasn't
in there to begin with
okay so you can play this game in much
more generality as I said instead of a
linear map you can take an arbitrary
continuous map or let's say a piecewise
linear map you can subdivide your
concept divide your complex first and
then map it you can also instead of a
single Ray you can think of some more
complicated curve that escapes to
infinity and the same reasoning would
apply
and it's actually not hard to show that
if you allow this greater generality
then you can represent any Co boundary
this way and any way any any D minus 1
dimensional coach and whose core
boundary it is alright ok so far so good
now ok that's that's what Kamala G & Co
chains and Co boundaries and Co cycles
but what does this have to do with
expansion so expire dimensional
expansion is a way of quantifying all
this so it's a way of quantifying the
fact that for instance the comb ology
doesn't vanish or or vanishes one way or
another so let's first look at graph
expansion and this is closest in spirit
for this is actually what I want to
discuss is a higher dimensional
generalization of edges edge expansion
so let's look at that first and I want
to talk about edge expansion in graphs
that are not necessarily sparse yes and
no so you can actually define everything
I've done here also over with other
coefficients it just becomes more
complicated but indeed there are some
geometric applications where for
instance I want to really count things
like the number of simply sees they'd
hit a point and then z2 is the right
coefficients to work with I might say
something about these letters of
instance you can instead of z2 you can
work with integer coefficients and then
what could happen if you learn more
complicated Maps is that for instance a
triangle gets folded or wrapped around
fault it is not a good point but imagine
that you take a triangle and you do
something like this
then if you look at the point
it turns out that the right thing to say
is not just that this triangle hits this
point but that this triangle hits this
point with multiplicity plus or minus
two depending on orientations and it
depends on what you want sometimes you
want to consider maps and you consider
all three images with multiplicity and
sometimes not the other reason is simply
that is over z2 you really get an
immediate generalization of edge
expansion okay so let's recall edge
expansion so graph with vertex at V and
edge said II has edge expansion eita
where this is some parameter Holtz well
every subsets of vertices you look at
the whole boundary just the address
going between s and its complement and I
want to talk about the non sparse case
or put possibly non sparse case so I
normalize I don't want that this is at
least ETA well what I can't just compare
it to the size of s because I might have
a very large set so the right thing to
do is either take s or take the
coordinates because it doesn't matter
this is completely symmetric oops and
this is not vertices edges
so in other words I mean this is a
normalized way of talking about edge
expansion where I assume that I have the
uniform distribution on both the
vertices and the edges and this kind of
makes sense okay so let's generalize
this here this is the same as a function
that eats vertices and spits of 0 or 1
again this is just the hemming norm what
is this let me write double squares for
the normalized Heming norm so what do we
really do here well we either take the
norm of s normalized or we take the norm
of s complement but this just means that
I take the minimum sorry thank you very
much yes yeah I want to measure the cob
Andriy and here I compared to the size
either of normalized size either of F or
of its complement which is the same as F
plus the constant one function what this
really is is the minimum in very fancy
terms of all ways of adding zero
dimensional Co bondrée there only to
either the constant 0 fine okay
so your ex is team here yes xst thank
you
okay so now once you have this
formulation it's kind of formally just
symbolically immediate how you
generalize let me maybe just introduce
one thing that we might need or maybe
not but anyway so let's say a simplicial
complex a bit of space little complex X
let's call boundary expansion
at least some parameter ETA in dimension
K more precisely for the Co boundary
that goes from dimension K minus 1 to K
the same thing holds so for every K
minus 1 dimensional code chain
I want that if I look at its core
boundary and I look at its normalized
hemming norm and this is at least my
expansion factor times the normalized
hemming norm of F not quite times
however small I can make the normalized
hemming norm of F by adding a KO
boundary
of the same dimension so this is my
defining in policy and the one last
thing let me just maybe write the
notation somewhere
where
so this I will use for the normalize
stemming norm another way of saying it
that maybe gender so here I would just
say if I take the standard hemming
normal just say I count how many ones
Michael Chen has and I divide by the
number of possible ones which is just
the number of simply seasons of that
dimension more generally in the spirit
of what we have been doing and seeing in
the previous talk you could assign some
system of weights to the simply sees of
your dimension of the dimension you're
looking at that sum up to one in other
words a probability distribution and
then this would just be the expected
weight of F of the simplex where the
simplex is drawn from the probability
distribution
now that probability distribution might
be uniform then you get the standard
normalized timing norm it might be this
kind of garland type distribution that
propagates downwards that we have seen
in the spectral case or it might indeed
be anything so with respect there's kind
of some choice of norm in the background
all right
second no not at all
no that is I mean there's for instance
and a result like for the constructions
of expanders one usually works with this
at least the existing constructions but
for instance there's an alternative
proof of a results in discrete geometry
maybe the number of three back
partitions that you can prove using a
very different norm so let me maybe just
mention the norm that might look stupid
suppose you have a bunch of n element
subsets this is not the layered
structure of a simplicial complex I just
want to describe the simplicial complex
which is complex and suppose you which
you label v1 then you could for instance
you can look at the simply C's which is
just u subsets of the union of these
vertices that contain at most one vertex
from each so this could be for instance
an admissible triangle and one norm that
turns out to be useful on the K
dimensional cochons is to give weight to
zero to all the simplices except the K
simply sees that only use vertices from
the first k plus one okay it's a it's
it's very much an aside but just to give
that turns out to be useful norm and
it's very different from the norms that
we usually see and and it turns out that
that has a useful application which I
will not no you can't because then you
don't get a simply show comp you want to
get four simplicial complex you need for
instance if you want to have top
dimensional simplices there would be
transversals if you want to simply show
complex so this would be a face
so you need to allow as a subset for
instance this face otherwise you don't
but I want this face of zero weight zero
okay anyway sorry this is very much a
distraction I didn't mean to talk about
this but right okay so this is the
definition it's one example
and I should say sorry about this
this definition arose independently they
didn't call it that way but in a paper
by not even the way
and independently in a paper bag or move
they didn't use this name but I like the
name so I will use it okay and the
example is also due to them as planet
says the kind of the the the sanity
check should be whether the complete
object is an expander
and indeed it is so this thing has gone
boundary expansion one and this is not
trivial it's not hard ex post facto once
you see the proof but it's not trivial
let me see I have about 15 minutes let's
take it on faith for now so for the
complete graph you can no boorish
readiness is related that's actually
what I want to say something about
I'm not running out of pen
yes so remark
it's function if I have a complex that
has expansion greater than zero in
dimension K this implies that H K minus
one is zero just like edge expansion
implies that my graph is connected which
means that H zero disappears it's a two
dimensional expansion larger than zero
implies that the first kamala G
disappears and so forth and it's a
quantitative version of this
why well let's look at the definition if
I have a K minus 1 dimensional coaching
it's core boundary is large compared to
its you can think of this as the
distance to this space of Co boundaries
but that means that if I have something
that is not a core boundary it has
nonzero distance this distance is
multiplied by something positive so
that's still positive so the norm of its
Co boundary must be positive so it's
nonzero so therefore anything that is
not a core boundary can haha cannot be a
core cycle all right what else do they
want to say
okay so there are essentially three
things I want to mention em you need I
was I want to say a few words about
topological overlap and boorish parody I
wanted to say maybe a couple of words
about other coefficients which I will
skip because we already touched upon
that and I wanted to also draw a
connection to oh yeah okay let me do do
another aside
inspired by what we saw earlier okay so
we define this for a simplicial complex
okay but if you look at the definitions
we don't really need a simplicial
complex or anything all we need is that
we have vector spaces over z2 we have
something that we call a Co boundary map
and we have some notion of sizes and the
expansion just says that we need at
least three vector spaces we look at the
middle one we look at Co boundaries of
things in the middle one and we want to
say they are large if whatever thing in
the middle we look at doesn't come from
something one layer down
so in short what I want to say is just
that you can also think of this as some
kind of property testing so in the
example that we saw earlier let's look
at linearity testing so there we had
some vector space Z 2 to the N we had
let's call this we had another vector
space which were the functions from V to
V su and we had a third vector space
that were the functions from pairs of
elements of V to Z 2 so we can put them
into a diagram like this where here we
just take a vertex and we map it to the
function that eats an element and just
sends it to the linear for me so this
just is the linear function defined by V
and if we have any function we can send
it exactly to sort of the test whether
it's linear locally
so this should be something that eats a
pear and this would just be this is this
expression and now what we what we saw
earlier is exactly that we when we are
so the image of the first Stelter
defines the linear subspace the linear
functions and linearity testing just
says that if we are far from that then
our quote-unquote Co boundary must also
be large so this Co chain complex if you
will is expanding okay all right what
else they want to say yes so I wanted to
talk about topological overlap
yes so all you need is essentially that
you have actor spaces you have linear
maps between subsequent ones so this
would be and what you usually want is
that you know the composition of two
subsequent ones is zero so that you have
some notion of comando G so such a thing
would be called the co chain complex
over Z to the other ingredient you need
is you need some kind of norm which you
typically specify by specifying a basis
in each dimension and then you can think
of the hemming norm you can do it more
generally but that would be the most
sort of natural way and and that's an
example this thing doesn't come from a
simplicial complex but it's still the
chain complex in fact an exact one that
has that has expansion wouldn't okay
this might matter I mean once one nice
thing about simplicial complex is for
instance is that if you think about
these properties like for instance about
the property of being a call cycle the
property that my own Co boundary
vanishes this is something that where
you need to check only you know a
bounded number of bits
yeah I mean definitely it's it's a it's
the notion of expansion depends not only
on the vector space on the linear
structure but on the choice of you have
you need to have some it's a
quantitative notion so it depends on the
quote on the notion of size or norm that
you involve okay what else do I want to
say yes okay
topological overlap let me maybe erase
this
so here's a result by gamma that I think
convinced a lot of people that I mean it
was in his paper among others that this
notion was introduced but I think it
also convinced a lot of people who are
maybe not so interested necessarily in
in anthropology to begin with that that
it's a very interesting concept and the
theorem is the following
suppose X is a simplicial complex and
that we can say something about the core
boundary expansion in dimension 1 2 and
so forth up to some dimension D that we
like
then for every map and let's say the
only thing I want to assume here is
there so I want to assume that the
distribution or the norm on the top
faces is uniform
then for every map of this complex there
exists a point continuous right yes map
I mean continues yes sorry from this
complex tour to the D they exists a
point that is heavily covered
at least some constant and I can even
try to see if I remember it or find it
in my notes written it down somewhere
so the fraction of top dimensional
simplices that will hit this point is
essentially the product of the expansion
factors times 1 over D factorial this is
not chart we don't know what the answer
is but when gamma and ok Glomus proof
gives something it's actually by a
factor of 2 larger but nevermind but
when he published this this was better
than anything that people have known
even in the special case of linear maps
and the complete complex and even for
the complete complex the optimal
constant is not known so there were
earlier results by Boros purity as
mentioned and antarean and others that
showed that there was some constant but
even this was the firing and definitely
no previous proof had said anything for
continuous Maps it has to decrease
exponentially indeed but it should the
common conjecture is that it should
decrease exponentially indeed not in d
log D the example is that you can have
in mind even though I'm lying a little
bit but it is anyway partition your
vertices into D plus 1 equal clusters
that you place at the vertices of a
regular simplex and that's your linear
map so in the plane you would map your
complete 2 dimensional complex you would
map n over 3 vertices here n over 3
vertices here n over 3 vertices here and
one can show that you can't essentially
do better than putting a point in the
middle so exponential decrease in D you
can't do anything about but it could be
something like e to the minus T instead
of
you mean higher dimension expansion in
spectral No
so I mean there are there are some
connections but what is definitely not
so for graph expansion at least if you
have to say regular graph you have a
[ __ ] inequality but you have to you
have to be a bit careful but you
definitely know this would this would be
this would be sort of bisection with
this is really this is really edge
expansion and for very irregular graphs
anyway it doesn't matter what this
definitely choose that in dimension two
and higher spectral expansion does not
capture Co boundary expansion is weak
this some people call this some people
call this topological expansion this
follows from Co boundary expansion but
it's not equivalent well up to the
dimension value if you have if you have
Co boundary expansion in dimension 1 up
to D you get topological expansion in
dimension 1 up to D so for maps into R 1
or 2 or 3 and so forth up to R to the T
but the other way around it's definitely
false that's right so and indeed there
are weakening
so as naughty says so to get this you
don't really need expansion like the
simplest case of this is d equal one
which says if you map a graph or any
complex onto the line there exists a
point with preimage intersects a
positive fraction of all edges and that
of course stays true if you have two
large cliques or something like that and
there is a corresponding weakening and
higher dimensions which goes under the
name of course systolic expansion that
is still sufficient
even that is stronger than it implies
topological overlap but you don't need
it you can weaken things further
but right right so there's it's
definitely okay so remark one remark -
okay I haven't I mean we have seen some
version of spectral expansion there a
different versions of spectral expansion
that really that for instance capture
real Co homology where you essentially
do everything the same except that
working over z2 you work over the reals
and instead of using the hemming norm
you use an l2 norm or a weighted l2 norm
on Co chains and then doing exactly the
same thing you get a notion of spectral
expansion terms of fire dimensional
laplacian over the reals you have to use
orientations yes but anyway neither that
version of spectral expansion or the
version of spectral igniter of the
versions of spectral expansion we have
seen implies Co boundary expansion but
there are results due to so okay so let
me write spectral expansion so I can so
this I mean it so one counterexample is
a probabilistic construction that I
don't really have time to describe I can
explain it offline body you can
construct for instance a two dimensional
complex even with a complete one
skeleton where the link of every vertex
is as good a spectral expander as you
could possibly hope for it essentially
looks like GN one half but still the
whole two-dimensional complex is not a
compounder expander
and that example for instance will have
all possible spectral properties that
you can hope for with the optimal
eigenvalue gaps and suppose so spectral
expansion does not imply call boundary
expansion
however sorry for those who are sit in
the corner I don't know where else to
write it I will put it here and I can
move the board yes excellent if only so
many I mentioned this before there are
what you could call local to global
results due to so by vitalii
Alex chai others that show that some
notions of spectral expansion or
sufficiently strong spectral expansion
for the underlying one skeleton and also
for all the links imply
something very related which I'll just
call expansion on small code trains
which is the name that these authors use
which means that which means that you
get a property like this but you don't
get it morally speaking for all F you
only get it for FS that are not too
large once you have this property no
there is a there's a screw here
unfortunately or maybe it stops even
before anyway and if you have this
property and if you additionally know
some further information for instance
that your complex is the two dimensional
skeleton of a three dimensional
Ramanujan complex or something along
these lines
you get furthermore Co systolic
expansion which I mentioned here but
didn't explain and from that you get for
instance examples of bounded degree
simplicial complexes in dimension two
and also higher dimension that have this
topological overlap property yes
yes I was lying that is true you need
the links to be Co boundary expanders I
was hoping to swap this and sweep this
under the carpet III wanted to tell a
story but you're completely right
okay so in short one thing we know is
that we know that they are sort of very
sparse KO systolic expanders and
therefore very sparse complexes with
this property but for Co boundary
expansion this story is more complicated
and in particular spectral expansion
doesn't that cannot give it so we can
look at the high dimensional this high
dimensional walk you there read you can
build up a graph right vertex whatever
phase and you can study the expansion of
this current and basically from from a
spectral expansion you get that the
specs or gap of this graph is about /
attention of this joint graph is not so
good it's like a ballot block like if
you just she goes they call it the edge
whereas what we can but you can prove is
that this graph is actually a small set
expanded so we do have a small sense in
this giant crap they actually expect so
it seems to be some analog of this thing
going on with a different language
language also saying that for functions
which are we have big norm you don't
expand function for a small norm you
expand is like a small so expanding so
just
I know I'm not saying that the same
maybe there is something skeptical but I
don't know I just want to mention that
here there is a trick that Charlie Alex
and Davide
found out that if you expand small sets
then essentially you get you're
expanding all of them except for the top
dimension so there is this pesky thing
that if you have a 100 dimensional
complex and you know you're expanding
small sets in all 100 dimension then
you're completely expanding except for
the like a peculiar 90999 so think you
get something slightly stronger than
your situation this will enable us to
get the cosy story we go see sonic is
not just small set expansion can release
state in words it's kosis Tolec
expansion means actually a cocoa
isoparametric pyramid well actually I
shouldn't say this because I'm using
more words than I should have
anyway never mind let me not say it
there was another question by him good
question
I can't definitely it's also I mean it's
maybe not so surprising because if you
think about the graph case the fact that
spectral expansion implies edge
expansion is essentially to reality
because its spectral expansion is
something like the the canonical semi
definite relaxation of a combinatorial
optimization problem and it's a
triviality that it provides a lower
bound but the fact that it provides also
an upper bound or that it's related you
need you know you need to work a bit I
mean you need the essentially spectral
partitioning which is there's some idea
there and I don't know I don't know if
there is in the right arms here makes no
so they're all the problems I mentioned
like the counter example and so forth
these you for instance the counter
example that I mentioned regarding ko
boundary expansion versus spectral
expansion it's essentially uniform so
the it just gives you more flexibility
and there are some applications where
this is useful but they study mentioned
so this kind of the analog of the norm
that you mentioned where everything is
induced from the top dimension this is
for instance what is what is used for
for these constructions I mean I think
it would be you know even even just
restricting to this norm there there it
comes sort of from the trickle-down
normal whatever we want to call it we
don't know how to analyze it properly
no questions
yes like some kind of testing right it
is local you it's it's it's a property
testing properties so Italian addicts
have a paper on this way I think you
discuss some more examples but I don't
remember I mean you can I mean as you
said so here you have the property of
being a co boundary you can kind of test
by looking at the code boundary of what
you are but that so I don't remember I
mean I I don't know of something sort of
really radically different no so there's
none but one other thing I should
mention which I forgot so so if you it
depends on what you mean by constant
degree or bounded degree so if you want
every vertex to be contained in a
bounded number of simply sees of all
dimensions then essentially no the best
sort of constructions give you complexes
that are of strongly bounded degree in
the sense that have weaker properties
like Co systolic expansion however there
are constructions due to Hui and Alex
robots ki and and due to Lobot ski so
lower yeah and one wasn't tell I think
of complexes there are sort of weakly
bounded degree so for instance of two
complexes that have a dense one skeleton
but where every edge is contained in a
bounded number of triangles and the same
in higher dimensions so weakly bounded
degree in this sense that exists but
even there I think the so these are
randomized constructions and I think in
a sense the analysis is a bit
unsatisfactory nits it's these are
beautiful results but
essentially they use ideas related to
this to prove expansion on small
coaching and then they use measure
concentration results on the large coach
ends which requires you to understand
very well sort of the tail bounds that
you get for the particular distributions
that you're probabilistic construction
provides but it's sort of so in a sense
I would say we don't have really good
criteria that you mean but do you mean
vertex degree or everywhere so I that
seems more feasible but I don't know of
of a construction that would yield it
like essentially it's I mean there there
is I should say there is another paper
by Esau and Anne Tolley where they give
a sort of a cone so so these
constructions here are based on ram
anujan complexes they give a different
simpler group theoretic construction
which as far as I know we still don't
know that their core boundary expanders
but but we hope so there might be but I
think in general it's like if you really
want fairly sparse complexes there is no
good random model as far as I know not
even with like logarithmic degrees
simply because I mean it's you know it's
kind of hard to construct something
where if you if you look from a vertex
ok that's fine but then you need to make
sure that there are enough kind of
triangle - enough edges that form
triangles with these emanating edges so
I don't know
like complex what they'll give you fool
yeah but that's a full ones full K
minus-1 skeleton
[Applause]